[Musica]
ted bologna è sempre un luogo di
incontro di tanta riflessione
salvaguardare il creato per forza perché
se il creato
viene salvaguardato viene sfruttato per
insultato da chi ha più capacità da chi
e piu forza viene tolto a chi domani non
lo avrà più o lo avrà talmente rovinato
da mettere in discussione la possibilità
stessa della vita
quelli sono un po pessimisti no non è la
logica conseguenza le risorse quelle
sono se tu le sfrutti all'infinito le
pieghe alla voracità del presente letoya
qualcun altro non si riformano
evidentemente è soprattutto un ambiente
sempre più segnato dall inquinamento ma
questo è un problema dell'ambiente
ma questo problema dell'uomo che deve
vivere nell'ambiente e nei tanti
campanelli d'allarme le tante sirene che
hanno cercato di svegliare tutti a
cominciare dai responsabili delle i
paesi delle nazioni della comunità
internazionale ma tutti quanti perché
tutti siamo coinvolti in questo dei
propri personali stili di vita e qualche
volta non abbiamo ascoltati abbiamo
pensato che fosse
una preoccupazione eccessiva abbiamo
pensato che fosse fossero soltanto dei
racconti di qualcuno che avevano altri
interessi
no credo che la preoccupazione per gli
creato salvaguardare il creato
vuol dire salvaguardare la persona poter
salvaguardare il futuro nostro e di chi
verrà dopo di noi passa per ognuno di
noi
certamente chi ha responsabilità deve
scegliere con determinazione con
convinzione non si può rimandare
siamo già al punto del non ritorno
ma questo passa anche per ognuno di noi
non è vero che ama tanto se lo faccio e
non lo faccio lo stesso
purtroppo questo avete aggiornamento
molto frequente dobbiamo farlo tutti
e i nostri stili di vita cioè se sto
attento allo spreco si sto attento a
come io tratto l'ambiente umano e il
creato
e sempre influente sempre decisivo
cominciamo da noi e con questo saremo
più convinti perché a chiedere ai nostri
governanti di di salvaguardare il creato